all right it was one year ago this
morning that Russian troops poured into
Ukraine launching a full-scale invasion
of that country and to mark that morning
in the capital of Kiev Ukraine's
president zielinski spoke to soldiers
and families of fallen troops in an
address to his Nation he congratulated
his people for fighting back and vowed
to defeat Russia's military this year 60
Minutes visited the city of her son
which Russia brutally occupied for eight
months until Ukraine's Army forced a
retreat back in November the recapture
of the city lifted hopes all across
Ukraine where Holly Williams found the
people of Harrison continue to live
their lives under Fire
things underground
it's too risky for mayor halina lahova
and her team to work in the town hall
secretary here so the administration of
a city the size of Saint Louis has been
crammed into this basement there are a
lot of problems we have and you see the
people who solve them and I'm just
noticing it's nearly all women there are
a lot of women here also yes that's
right
[Laughter]
they've had to improvise
to keep the buses running Parts have
been salvaged from those hit by shells
and the Heat at this hospital is off
most days so that wisps of steam don't
catch the attention of Russian Artillery
spotters I've heard that you like to
describe Harrison as Invincible
why did you choose that word we are
unbreakable all the people of Ukraine
are Unbreakable
and Holly Williams is with us now at the
table uh Holly you've been covering the
story uh for the full year uh since the
invasion and you were covering the
conflict prior to that as well with what
you know what is the most important
thing Americans should know about the
people of Ukraine uh well Tony
ukrainians never wanted this war they're
being killed sometimes in their own
homes they desperately want peace but
they are not willing to hand over a
chunk of their country to Vladimir Putin
in the hope that he then leaves them
alone I mean just imagine a similar
situation in the U.S imagine there was a
bigger more powerful country that
invaded the US killed a lot of Americans
and then some people said you know maybe
you should hand over Minnesota yeah
maybe you guys should hand over Montana
and then maybe they'll stop killing
Americans I don't think that people in
this country would agree to that and
ukrainians don't either speaking of what
the American people want to know in this
time of economic hardship Financial
instability for a lot of people I think
people at home want to know why are we
pouring so much money reso forces into
Ukraine how do you answer that right so
I think this is not just about Ukraine
if Vladimir Putin is allowed to take a
bite out of Ukraine what's to stop him
doing it next time to another country
what's to stop another
authoritarian-minded regime China say
looking at that and saying well you know
we might start to do the same thing
right um so the U.S and its friends
believe that if Vladimir Putin is
allowed to get away with invading
Ukraine then it makes the world a much
less stable place a much more dangerous
place for everyone including Americans
and that's why they're giving so much
Aid billions of dollars in Aid including
military aid to the ukrainians you talk
about the the rule-based order and if
that collapses we may feel safe and snug
here across an ocean in America but
it'll have economic Ripple effects that
would touch Us and other consequences we
can't even imagine exactly right yeah
and maybe conflicts that America does
get drawn into all right Holly Williams
thank you for your reporting great to
see you here in person good to see you
too you can watch Holly's report this
Sunday on 60 Minutes right here on CBS